principles for success an ultra
mini-series adventure in 30 minutes and
in eight episodes episode 1 the call to
adventure before we begin let me just
establish the fact that I don't know
much relative to what I need to know
whatever success I've had in life has
more to do with my knowing how to deal
with my not knowing than anything I know
that I should be telling other people
what to do sounds kind of presumptuous
to me but I'm going to do it because I
believe that the principles that have
made me successful could help others
achieve their own goals I'm now at a
stage in my own life in which it is much
more important to me to pass along what
I've learned about how to be successful
than to seek more success for myself
what you choose to do with these
principles is up to you you have to be
an independent thinker because only you
can develop your own principles based on
your own values this brings me to my
first and most fundamental principle
which is that you need to think for
yourself about what is true so let's get
started early on I discovered I needed
principles principles are smart ways for
handling things that happen over and
over again in similar situations there
are principles for everything from
skiing to parenting to cooking and so on
I'm going to share some of my most
important overarching life principles
that influence how we approach
everything
I didn't start out with principles I
acquired them over a lifetime of
experiences mostly from making mistakes
and reflecting on them my life
principles are simple but they're not
complete I still struggle to make the
best decisions and I still make mistakes
and learn new principles all the time
this is the reality at the beginning I
needed to escape the conventions that
surrounded me which meant that I needed
to think for myself unless you want to
have a life that is directed by others
you need to decide for yourself what to
do and you need to have the courage to
do it but I didn't know that at first I
only learned that from going on my
adventure looking back on my own journey
I now see the time is like a river that
carries us forward into encounters with
reality that require us to make
decisions we can't stop our movement
down this river and we can't avoid the
encounters we can only approach them in
the best possible way in your lifetime
you will face millions of decisions the
quality of your decisions will determine
the quality of your life over the course
of my lifetime the most valuable things
I've learned were the results of
mistakes I reflected on to help form
principles so I wouldn't make the same
mistakes again these principles took me
from being a very ordinary middle-class
kid from Long Island to becoming very
successful as judged by conventional
measures they also gave me the
meaningful work and meaningful
relationships that I value even more
than these conventional successes people
often ask me how I did it I can assure
you it wasn't because of my uniqueness
as a person it was the result of a
unique approach to life I believe almost
anybody can adopt it starts with
embracing reality and dealing with it in
Episode two I'll explain what that means